[Music]
mcdonald's is getting into the nft craze
oh boy
ah can you make rib
that's just gonna be worse no way
they're not giving very many away either
you got to get on twitter is the mcrib
back are they giving them away they're
giving them away
on twitter
and yeah you're not going to win it's
probably it's probably i think it's
already been distributed at this point
because it happened on november 1st
but yeah this is um part of the new
craze we're like i mean dude we're
reaching a point in the cycle right now
where all these companies are launching
nfts and [ __ ] and it's getting really
really similar to how it was in 2018
where you know we reached like a max
capacity before everything went down are
people really excited about
like big companies nfts though i mean
people want nfts because they're called
entities right now and that equals money
to them
yeah like just the hype is so big
there's that big auction recently right
with a bunch of like like those like
monkeys or some board board
yeah yeah like getting all sold or
whatever on ethereum yeah yeah how much
are they getting sold for you know it's
like somebody i think one of like a
rapper bought one for like a couple
million or something like that called
boarding board 8 yacht club oh isn't
that the first
that's why it's one no crypto yeah
crypto pumps is the first oh gee
this one's like the high end one right
like by the way who blew up board it
um it is honestly it was kind of like
just a viral thing that happened jason
chen did
but there was some celebrities who got
involved as well like um but basically
they're some of them have gone for like
100 like tens of millions of dollars
tens of millions dude i heard like caa
was like gonna start representing them
or like buying four or eight yeah i just
don't know i don't even understand the
draw to stuff like that yeah i wish i
did i know because i would like to i'd
like to play but i just don't understand
like even with like base or basketball
baseball cards okay cool you have a star
player you know he changed his street or
whatever i get it one of one superman
condition there is a video that explains
also how you can kind of double your net
worth by buying and
use like all the winnings you take on
crypto or whatever yeah
into uh the nft space it's kind of like
using
cash and art in the real world to avoid
taxes to avoid taxes and all that but
also to um increase the value or
something like that like the mechanism i
understand right like buying things of
assets and stuff like that but then in
the real world when you have a van gogh
or whatever it's like this guy was a
part of history so that that's the part
i'm trying to understand like the it is
still a part of history it's just new
history exactly well that's the the
biggest thing about nft is just like
the the scam ability is super [ __ ]
high yeah so that's why people are a
little iffy about it right because like
one of the
the original art that was sold the most
before all this board [ __ ] was people's
art right so people is [ __ ] huge he's
always been a huge artist he makes a new
art piece every [ __ ] day super
impressive his digital rpgs are [ __ ]
amazing too right so at the time there
was so i haven't seen that but i think i
would lean more towards actually
understand that versus those don't look
like it took much skill exactly so now
you have people like like logan paul
he's doing his thing and it's you know
it's trash but somehow has value to it
yeah you know so this is where it starts
to get a little [ __ ] [ __ ] weird
yeah because the original like idea
behind nfts or why artists really like
it was based on the fact that it allows
artists to make money so a lot of the
times when you have these things that
are digital arts they're jpegs right you
have it anybody can copy it isn't that
the one that sold for the most 80 mil
wow
so you never [ __ ] know and so uh this
guy that i had on my podcast named tim
king he bought one for 777 thousand
dollars and i think that when by the
time he came to the podcast it was
already worth like 1.2 whoa yeah people
are flipping these things like crazy
yeah uh i'm not i'm holding nfts right
now i'm scooping them but yeah it's it's
a huge industry right now which is i
mean it's like art and one of the cool
things about them too is so like if you
if you scroll down this is open c's one
of the main ones
um they have all the different
attributes like the rare attributes so
people can kind of judge for themselves
not even based on personal preferences
but based on
whoever issues it can make it rarer yeah
each one that they issue what's open c
openc is just a platform for nft
launches i was hearing at the board ape
yacht club they were having like pretty
much like road maps of if you buy one of
these
the owner of whoever created this will
give you like special um
like rare pieces that'll go along with
it and then it could change your monkeys
like uh look yeah if you get like two or
three different serums then it'll be
like a zombie one you can mutate them
yeah and that'll become like
three in a row of one exclusive brand
and then you could sell that for even
more because everybody wants a
collection so they gamified the
investment depending on who's doing it
right you could also
make it so every time it changes hands
the artist will always get a percentage
of the cut for what it's sold for so for
example it's worth like 2 000 when you
bought it right but then it sells for 4
million well there's a thing inside that
nft that says i get 40 of that smart
contract yes so there you go so it
allows a lot of like power to be given
back to the artist for them to actually
make money off of their art so each time
it changes transaction the artist wins
and i hear a lot of like really high-end
like art galleries are getting into the
nft space because they're like we might
as well right because it's it's such a
hot commodity whether they think it's
it's not even just art right you you
could put the medical industry into nfts
and it would be easier for doctors to
have your records if it's an nft so like
it's all in the blockchain it's all a
public ledger right all the doctors can
see it like that well no you could use
privacy networks in order to secure it
so that you can keep your information
private but then the doctors could
access it as an nft and then it would be
nice and clean you don't have to worry
about record keeping being sloppy which
kills thousands of people a year i don't
know if a lot of people know that and
even doctors handwriting kills shady
handwriting shitty handwriting kills
thousands of people a year so imagine
that's why your [ __ ] relative died
you couldn't read your [ __ ]
prescription you know but yeah putting
this stuff on the blockchain and making
it and creating an um a public ledger
for it is super beneficial in many ways
that people aren't even thinking about
making these [ __ ] entities are
expensive too because there's gas fees
and [ __ ] they can be but if you go to
there's certain places if you go to
mintable for example if you're an artist
out there go to mentable and you can
print them for free wow yeah and so you
don't pay gas um to mint them it's the
advantage of paying gas though some
obviously people are doing it uh they're
doing it to get on open c generally
because on open c i'm pretty sure you
have to pay gas to get an open seat at
least that's a bigger market or bigger
exposure yeah it's way bigger marketing
open c is like where everybody goes
right now to get into the appeal of an a
owning an nft is just bragging rights
and a theoretical increase in value for
the future it's uniquely yours like it's
it's yours so like
this one's yours yeah and nobody else um
has it you could you could argue right
now i can control click and save it but
it's not yours on the blockchain right
so it's but it's bragging rights so like
it's just to say that you own it yeah
it's it's it's yeah it's uniquely yours
just like i could copy the mona lisa
right now hang it on my wall but it's
not the mona lisa so it's the same ideas
the louvre can be like we have the mona
lisa and they do and they make money off
of it i wish i was smart enough to
understand dude as you do understand not
dude i'm like why do people want a
monkey wearing three glasses why do
people want to buy a shoe very true well
there's utility yeah but they don't ever
wear it they just display it and they
put in the closet or like why do they
want a [ __ ] hundred thousand dollar
gun that they'll never shoot but it has
like a historical but all a lot yeah
exactly the historical meaning to it
it's built into the story the narrative
i don't know who made that but do people
know yeah that's why it's it's it's
yeah yeah yeah because there's there's a
story to different ones like the
cyberpunks is the first or whatever and
then or like the tarah whales one that
you know you guys were getting into it's
gonna be you know for the terra network
so it's kind of like a meme for all the
terror whales yeah there's a lot of the
collectible stuff in the physical world
what makes that thing so valuable to
people is that it also transcended its
own industry
right like if you buy the chris kyle
rifle not only is it used in afghanistan
during that time it was an american
sniper or whatever like there's like it
goes like jordan's like you don't even
people don't even know basketball they
they love they love jordan or they love
what it's about or you know there's like
it transcends it like uh so i understand
where it becomes part of like the
cultural and societal fabric that we're
in the i'm still trying to understand
this one's more niche so it's like it's
kind of like
stab collecting or like just any type of
collecting and niche marketplace but
this is just it just so happens that the
people involved are just
deep pockets why do people buy newer
right like contemporary art is actually
one of the highest um nfts no no
contemporary art is one of the highest
grossing like art like you you you like
yeah rembrandts and all these are mad
money but contemporary art you'll get
like 75 plus on like games uh and also
nike just filed a trademark to get into
nfts as well yeah they're looking at
making
nfts for video games like fortnite
uh and for branding and i do think that
the novelty of just like everyone
talking about it and it's new and how
everyone's bum rushing the market is
also creating this like hype around it
building the foundation for the future
hey but also who knows if the value will
stick you know what i mean like you
can't predict that it might be like
beanie babies for
a lot of this [ __ ] which i think it's
gonna be a lot of this [ __ ] the value's
not gonna hold no way yeah it's not what
about but the only different element
here is that it's also like
like contemporary or any art where like
you can kind of hide money and add value
to your money by owning these things too
well like i own some of the i own the
first tom brady and athena ever were
made right and i'm just counting on that
being why they're valuable i think
that's it you know what i mean it's just
[ __ ] like that the like tom brady agreed
that this is the first time writing
stuff like that i think i understand
more because i could like equate that to
football cards baseball cards whatever
just the other ones i don't know maybe
i'm just thinking about it like this art
doesn't mean [ __ ]
like the way it's valued is so
superfluous it's only somebody who
[ __ ] is rich that goes this is worth
money that's why it's worth money
exactly that is how obscure art
evaluation is right and if there's no
buyers then it's not worth that much but
if there's five millionaires that are
fighting over this [ __ ] jar of
peanuts no matter if we go dude you
could buy this i could remake it they're
like i don't care but there's five
millions
five millionaires fighting over this pro
this bag of peanuts or whatever no it's
worth that now it's worth that much
that's all it is and how relevant is it
right because like my uncle bob had a
huge combo collection that was worth
like half a million dollars and
the most popular ones were not the ones
that he was buying as a boy necessarily
like like some monster house or some
[ __ ] that nobody's ever heard of some
science fiction comics and nobody's ever
heard of it's all super boy number one
superman number one or like spider-man
number one the stuff that lasted right
the stuff that like
went throughout generations but like if
he had i mean back then if he had
guardians of the galaxy number one
nobody gave a [ __ ] it was like 1995.
nobody gave a [ __ ] right so like because
they brought that back dusted off
brought it to a new generation that's
worth something again but like how much
is this old arc gonna be worth something
to a lot of younger people who are
growing up getting money you know what
i'm saying so this is like like pokemon
cards when you're a kid you're a lot of
parents threw away pokemon cards yeah
right my parents threw
gave all my pokemon cards to this
[ __ ] kid i hated yep and like i went
to college i came back i like wearing
those cards and she goes oh i gave it to
that kid i was like where's he moved to
korea i was like you [ __ ] [ __ ] yep
and then so like a couple of years ago i
hunted him down i found
everything i had was like a mint first
edition and i sent my mom like ebay
links i was like this is how much money
you threw away i was like you [ __ ]
idiot and why are they valuable because
we all grew up and we agreed that
they're valuable and now we're just
older with deeper pockets that's it and
we're the ones who make the money yeah
like i went on ebay and looked for some
old lego sets that i always wanted it
was a pirates collection now it's worth
thousands dude exactly bro i wanted that
too oh and i will buy it i will i will
buy it
dude i will front run you're not i'll
buy it i'll buy that [ __ ] and i'll have
a pirate ship right here and i'll be
like look at my pirate ship [ __ ]
[Music]
you